offenbar hat Russland in der Nacht zum
Mittwoch zwei Drohnen über dem Kreml
abgeschossen das sagt zumindest das
russische Präsidialamt ein Anschlag auf
Präsident Putin sei geplant gewesen Kiew
dementiert mit diesem Angriff etwas zu
tun zu haben sie wissen natürlich auch
nicht wer es war aber wonach sieht das
Ganze denn für Sie aus
das ist schwer einzuschätzen weil
sozusagen alle Optionen Sinn und keinen
Sinn machen also eine Force Flack attack
Seiten der russischen Regierung selber
zeigt eigentlich nur wie schwach die
russische Regierung ist dass sie jetzt
diese Bilder eines brennenden Senats in
in Moskau braucht um ihren Krieg zu
rechtfertigen wenn es Ukrainer waren
oder sozusagen Anti Kreml Gruppen in
Russland dann war das natürlich ein
massives Versagen des russischen
Militärs und des russischen
Geheimdienstes also die
Luftverteidigung in Moskau ist
anscheinend seit Matthias Rust auf dem
Roten Platz gelandet ist 1987 hat sich
nicht verbessert bei nah fliegenden und
tiefliegenden Objekten
das ist ein sofern eigentlich eine
peinliche Aktion wir haben es eben in
dem Bericht auch gehört im
Staatsfernsehen werden diese Bilder gar
nicht erst gezeigt
ja es ist eine peinliche Aktion es ist
auffällig dass diese Bilder erst nach 12
Stunden gezeigt werden weil diese
Attacken fanden ja in der Nacht statt
wir haben die Bilder erst seit ein paar
Stunden es ist auffällig dass sozusagen
es mittlerweile Videos gibt die aus 12
verschiedenen Kamerapositionen diese
Attacke zeigen also da passt ganz viel
einfach nicht zusammen und deutet sehr
viel einfach darauf hin dass hier auch
ein massives Versagen der russischen
Politik vorher herrscht egal wer es war
ob sozusagen Ukrainer waren Anti
russische Gruppen oder ob es der Kreml
selbst war Präsident selenski der
ukrainische Präsident hat ja gesagt er
vermutet dass man damit das russische
Volk quasi zusammenschweißen will und
die Soldaten die russischen mehr
motivieren um noch mehr sich
mobilisieren zu lassen oder an die Front
zu gehen könnte da was dran sein
das könnte in der Tat ein Motiv gewesen
sein wenn es der Kreml selber war es
offenbart aber natürlich auch die
Schwäche des Krems mit Blick auf diesen
Krieg dass man jetzt solche Bilder
braucht um die Kriegsmoral in der
russischen Bevölkerung hochzuhalten
könnte da hinterher auch eventuell noch
die Hoffnung stecken dass man den Westen
und Ukraine spaltet also hat ja auch
heute sofort betont haben es eben gehört
also wir greifen nicht auf russischen
Territorium an das ist ja gewisse Massen
so dass griemend zwischen den westlichen
Unterstützern und hier für da keine
roten Linien zu überschreiten
naja es ist aber so dass die Ukraine ja
schon des öfteren auf russischen
Territorium natürlich nicht so weit in
Russland selber militärische Ziele
angegriffen hat also von daher glaube
ich dass ich hier der Westen nicht
spalten lassen würde da Völkerrechtler
es ist zwar umstritten aber der
Völkerrechtler durchaus argumentieren
dass der Kreml ein legitimes Ziel ist
weil natürlich aus dem Kreml diese
militärischen Operation auch
mitgesteuert werden ich glaube was man
sagen muss was auszuschließen ist
angesichts dieser zwei Drohnen ist dass
das eine gezielte Attacke auf putin war
also dazu hätte dann die Ukraine oder
andere Kräfte Informationen gebraucht wo
sich Putin genau aufhält im Kremmen und
ich glaube nicht dass er sozusagen unter
der Dachkuppel schläft sondern eher in
sehr stark gesicherten Räumen wenn er
sich im Gremmel aufhält deswegen würde
ich diese Interpretation ausschließen
dann gab es ja in den letzten Stunden in
den letzten Tagen immer wieder Angriffe
sie sagten das gerade dann fliegt einen
Treibstoffdepot in die Luft oder dann
entgleist ein russischer frachtzug
könnten das schon die Vorboten der von
allen erwarte ten ukrainischen gegen
Offensive sein
ja also es ähnelt sehr der Situation im
Juni letzten Jahres wo die Ukraine
versucht haben massiv sozusagen
russische Nachschubwege russische
Logistik zu zerstören und das was man
sozusagen das Schlachtfeld zu Formen
betrieben haben um eine offensive
vorzubereiten und von daher
interpretiere ich diesen entgleisten Zug
und diese Raffinerie Anschläge die wir
in den letzten Tagen erlebt haben genau
in diese gleiche Richtung also man
versucht sozusagen diese Offensive
gezielter vorzubereiten russische
Truppen von Nachschub abzuschneiden
danke schön für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
es sind niedrig fliegende Objekte die
sich dem Kreml in der Nacht zu Mittwoch
nähern dann eine Explosion diese Bilder
kursieren durchs Netz lange bevor der
Kreml am Nachmittag offiziell verkündet
zwei unbemannte ukrainische Drohnen
sollen laut Moskau einen Angriff verübt
haben auf Russland und auf Vladimir
Putin wir betrachten diese Aktionen als
einen geplanten Terroranschlag und ein
Attentat auf den Präsidenten das vor dem
Tag des Sieges und der Parade vom 9 mai
verübt wurde der Präsident ist bei
diesem Terroranschlag nicht zu Schaden
gekommen
Putin habe sich nämlich in einer
Residenz außerhalb von Moskau
aufgehalten wie diese Aufnahmen belegen
sollen der angebliche Drohnenangriff ist
bereits der dritte größere Vorfall auf
russischem Boden binnen weniger Stunden
gestern Vormittag ging ein öldepot in
grasnodar in Flammen auf am Dienstag
entgleiste ein Zug mit Versorgungsgütern
bei brianski wegen einer Explosion beide
Male Beschuldigte Russland ukrainische
sabbateure der ukrainische Präsident
dementiert am Abend während seines
überraschenden Besuchs in Helsinki für
die Drohnenangriffe verantwortlich zu
sein für die Ukraine sei es ein reiner
Verteidigungskrieg
wir greifen weder Putin noch Moskau an
wir kämpfen aus unserem Territorium wir
verteidigen unsere Regionen und Städte
die Menschen in Kiew haben ihre ganz
eigene Meinung zu dem vermeintlichen
Drohnenangriff ich glaube nicht dass es
die Ukraine war die Russen neigen dazu
ihr eigenes Territorium anzugreifen und
uns dann die Schuld zu geben
es
muss brennen wie alle unsere Städte
brennen
alles ist möglich solange die Ukraine
nicht offiziell bestätigt dass dies ein
Angriff von uns ist kann es viele
Theorien darüber geben wer es war
[Musik]
die Feierlichkeiten am 9 mai sollen in
Moskau aber wie geplant stattfinden